[Music]
welcome to winners on the Wednesday this
week we've got two absolutely awesome
guys in a great couple we're going to be
talking about rent to rent so please
welcome onto the show Jordan and Jess
thank you very much really good to see
you again so you guys are killing it at
the moment why don't you just tell me
before we go on to talk about what
you've done what you've built up maybe
just tell me your backgrounds so what's
your kind of what's your background
before you yeah first my background
basically leave in school I'm real
passionate about cars so I went straight
down that route I left a witness to do
apprenticeship and blah blah blah I
wanted to go to Formula One so I was
working for McLaren and then at some
point I kind of decided that you know
what I want to achieve more and you know
just get to the next pay grade and that
wasn't really enough for me so then I
started actually funnily enough I went
home after a night shift and I started
tapping into YouTube you know you know
how to make money and then how to make
money property come up and how to invest
in property and it was one of your
videos cuz it was like I think it was
like a million now at 21 isn't it I know
it was one of those videos and
interviews me any order yeah it's the
most random video but 74,000 comes up it
comes up like first one so that that's
that brought me straight to you
basically that's that was and then from
there watching their videos that's when
I knew from that point that I wanted to
get into property learn more about come
down to do some courses and get involved
and that's I was going to go back
awesome answer your background he's kind
of like Carl yeah yeah watch watch the
video on YouTube came down met me at the
crash course how about you Jess mine's
kind of all over the place I wanted to
do hate be bossed around by other people
and I've been in some estate agent jobs
now so learning the ins and outs that
sort of thing and how I got into
property was Jordan actually begged me
to come to the first seminar I ever went
to yeah cool love that love that and you
guys are not old how old are you guys 22
22
like the song Taylor Swift epic and so
so that's
background young hungry entrepreneurs I
know when we met you were like saying I
do not want to be working for a better
whatever you are like I'm the man man so
so it's kinda thought I know we've done
you know we've done some one-on-one
training as well to be fair you've been
to the crash course you've you've been
here in the offices for training so why
don't you just tell us because when you
tell me about the crash course tell me
about course is amazing so me and
Jessica have actually both been training
before the crash course both paid and
free as well and the thing about the
crash course is awesome I let's remember
our conversation after the crash course
when we came out we was like this is
this is the best course like all round
they're just for sheer value because
that's what that's what it is a shared
value I'll tell you exactly what I mean
so so we paid thousands of pounds for
courses in the past and nobody has ever
shown it's like okay so his right move
and here's how you find ideal
step-by-step this is where it click on
this is what you do this is how you find
it for HMO a single let a lease option I
didn't even know finding the lease
option was possible on Rightmove but I
didn't know the technique did not know
how to do it and then also you know a
previous courses people tell you sort of
what to say and stuff but it's kind of
like there's always a missed a bit of a
cloud you know like well somebody says
it's what somebody says that but I know
what your core so you literally just
pick up the phone and do it them and
their line with several occasions you
just pick up the phone and you just go
for it some good response some bad
responses real life and we can see how
you react to it and for me that was just
a massive learning point I'll never
forget it oh I appreciate that bro you
know what respect bro respect I remember
you said big energies big and you
actually said you know whoever's a
millionaire come up on stage right now
and I really ran that Jordan or maybe B
ran and we were doing a lot silly
dancing on Sarah and you really made us
feel like really confident cuz we would
never do anything oh no I would say and
that's a good idea
yeah you just made us feel like it's a
really safe environment and you I mean
you could do anything yes that's how you
made us feel because there's a time
there's a time to be serious there's a
time to have fun and and if you're not
getting out of your comfort zone yeah
how you gonna pick up the phone
yeah it's not because it was a massive
point for us and I would say wow that
the crash cord is not just is not just a
property course it's a phenomenal
experience because our goal ultimately
is to look on wealthy right and I
remember at the crash course store Zen
you would teach and like the
fundamentals of well so like bank
accounts how to set up your bank
accounts um we need to have this sort of
thing and then like to pay yourself
first and that sort of things that
really helped us as well so I love that
I really appreciate that guys and then
after the crash course I know you
started implementing you started putting
together your business plan and you
started vlogging the journey hey check
them out on Facebook start vlogging the
journey and then you thought you know
what you really thought you'd fly more
by doing a little bit of one-to-one
coaching so you came to the offices what
did I say when you presented your
business plan to me Jordan
so basically just you just run leather
and he just tore in how we came in
really you know bubbly happy over the
moon with this mega piece of art we put
together and it was a business plan and
basically it had so much stuff and it
was a bit of a mess now we see was a
mess yeah he was so proud of we were so
proud he was that you're gonna do this
I'm gonna do that there was sa rents
rent lease options B&B deal package and
a lot and the nudists basically goes
guys tore apart he goes look we just
narrow it down focus on something focus
on and we went we went with rent to rent
all together and the very quickly after
that we saw our results yeah oh man when
we focused on home yeah because you had
all these because I think is some funds
with with properties which when you
start going on property courses you can
be like a kid in a sweet shop because
that's a great strategy that's a great
that's good we don't want to like spare
any of you wanted to just do everyday
yeah or like what and they say if you
try and chase two rabbits
you'll catch non because so sure when
you just say you know what forget that
what a focus is focusing on one thing at
once until successful and then you can
then see what's next and you know I
think that was um what I gave you was
good advice because it's clearly worked
because now you've got you how many
rental rents five rental rates high five
man haha
thank you
on average how much is each meant to
rent Kannan bringing you in profit so on
each one yeah I would say around 750
between 700 and 800 pounds all of them
so in total once they're all fully let
will bring us about four and a half
thousand pounds that's nice and you say
what's wrong for that because you've
literally I mean you just you picking up
the keys still two months and we still
got just sign for two so they're common
with the next couple of weeks we've got
to fully let ones going through a reefer
but it's all you got loads of viewings
coming into that before I remember
seeing the pictures on facebook when you
you first got the property you got the
keys and then and then like a few a
couple weeks like there's another
picture where you know yeah how does it
feel seeing the money actually coming in
oh it's amazing
it's so good like literally is it's it's
weird because you it's almost like you
don't get too much time to reflect but
then when you do think back I thought
well now we've got properties and
they're paying us and yeah I'm not
working anymore by the way I'm I'm
full-time now so it's incredible but
it's what happened it's always happening
quickly but it's weird but it's amazing
and when did you just just to get Thomas
girls right when did we first meet at
the crash course and when did you do
your mentoring so we met was a crash was
the thing was up back into the summer
was it July or something like that six
months yes yeah yeah we done our
mentoring soon after that was I said
10th October and then we've got first in
and we've got two deals in November and
then three in January yeah fantastic
fantastic that's so exciting so so
you've now quit your job because I mean
for four thousand four and a half
thousand a month that's a pretty decent
I mean for some people that's two
salaries and that's not quite fully
passive but it's close enough because
you're managing the name yourself is
that right yeah and where are you where
are you where are these port where are
these properties
doana commented oh and where do you live
commentary fantastic you know I I teach
that it doesn't have to be close to
where you live here because it might
just have to happen that you live in an
area which isn't particularly good for
you so don't rule out investing
elsewhere but I think sometimes people
set that to the extreme and then
everybody's looking like really bad or
yet or scag
which is which can can work but I think
it's really good to see people actually
in their own area with one strategy
smashing out the park
I mean commentary is not too far from
our church in Coventry you've even
joined up yeah so you know tell me how
you are how are you finding these
properties who are the landlord's you're
speaking with give me some give me some
advice give us some nuggets yeah so
we've got how many different lands
there's three different language so two
of the properties have come from direct
to landlord and so that was through
direct mail campaigns yeah and other
three have all come through agents so we
call a page and it's find the properties
we like on Rightmove call up the agents
go for viewers would then build some
rapport let them know you know that
we're serious about what we do or
looking to take on of our properties and
then yeah then they just they they
basically could trust us and we went
ahead with the first one that went
really well and then they gave us two
more so incredible you know what I
always say a good relationship is better
than a good deal yeah because and if you
think about it you're now making four
grand plus a month from from just three
landlords yeah exactly people they're
the seven billion people on the planet
so true so true and many at many are
many occasions landlords have more than
one property so the first landlord got
the property from he gave us the second
one after that and he's got about twenty
in his portfolio and it just so happens
that those two weren't at the time but
now that you can see that were adding
value to his house we've decorated the
place and he can trust us I'm doing a
good job yeah I'm you know I think he'd
be willing to work with us even more in
the future so that's fantastic I'm
really proud of you guys tell me a
little bit about how much money did you
have to start with to to investing in
this program and portfolio did you a big
pot did you have nothing I let you go
doing a lot speaking how much would you
say we had to start when we took our
first went to rent on we had nothing we
didn't have any money we got it direct
to landlord we negotiated with him a
two-week rent-free period because we
simply just didn't have the money to pay
oh yeah hold on so you had a landlord he
agreed to give you his property on a
retro basis and then you had to
renegotiate yeah to have it free for two
weeks yeah yeah
so how do you do that what did you say
just well what happened was we were
going I was going back and forth for a
very long time emailing calling trying
to break down the figures to him and say
this whole figure you'll get in is not
what you're getting after the voids
after maintenance after all of that and
then finally one day you picked up the
phone and said and I want you to corral
my house and have a chat with me so me
and Jordan are best suits went round
there and we got grilled and interviewed
by our yeah and then he gave us the keys
the next day so Wow yeah so you
obviously you obviously handled yourself
super well yeah an hour and I think
that's as well like you guys come in
from position with very little money to
invest but then the little money that
you did have spending on training yeah
yeah so then when you're in a situation
whereby you're getting grilled for an
hour yeah yeah yeah so the practice and
the trainer really comes in it yeah yeah
so okay so you negotiated two weeks
yeah just for anyone that's watching
this it's thinking what on earth like
what he's went to rent and you started
have nothing and now you're making four
grounds here maybe maybe just summarise
so anyone that's not quite sure what
what is a renter in and what because
you're not in serviced accommodation
either you're doing or just take em out
yeah so tell us what are intermittent is
okay so essentially what we do is we
rent a property as a whole from a
landlord we agree we negotiate a rent
upfront and then we agree on that rent
we'll take it for a long period usually
between three and five years and then
we'll guarantee that rental figure to
the landlord for the entire length of
the contract yeah so regardless that we
ever remember you're not that landlord
is now I never been experienced avoid
because we made them commitment to him
or her and so then we take that property
and we rent it out on his HMO on a
room-by-room basis which then maximizes
the profit so we've got enough then to
cover the bills so we call the bills in
our service and then we pay the landlord
and then there's profit left for us
afterwards as well fantastic love that
great explanation yes it is and is that
completely legal it is yes yep it's
legal simply because of fact we have the
right contracts and play somewhere we
have a limited company in place which is
acts as the management for the property
so yeah so cuz because sometimes again
people say is that legal that sounds
like subletting you want to see
no can't see it and that's the blame but
to some of them you don't get past so
you simply don't get past them but some
agents you will be able to say you know
lets me open the property talk explain
it to you yeah I know they do they do
understand cuz you managed to win over
an estate agent and a couple of
landlords which is great so what are the
risks associated with ready to rent
obviously there's risks if you don't do
your market research and your due
diligence so much you know you've got to
do you've got to do your research
properly to make sure the area you
choose to invest in has demand there
because the last thing you want to do is
you know take a property from my
landlord spend some money on it adding
value to the property so it's all nice
and ready to rent out and then have it
empty that's the last thing you want so
definitely yeah because yeah because
you've you know you've obliged to pay
that pay the rent to the landlords yeah
you definitely want to do some research
to make sure that the area has demand so
you're not gonna be losing out on money
I would say that's probably one of the
main facts is it is yeah also I'd say
one of the other main things is if you
are taking on an HMO that's obviously
the law change where you need to HTML
licensing if it is more than five people
in the property to make sure it's five
or more people now isn't it so yeah yeah
absolutely and I think as well like
although rent to rent strategy is
brilliant if you've got no or very
little money yeah you do need to not you
doing don't ya yeah you don't go you
know if you take on a property and
you've got no money and then you can't
rent it out and you've not got money to
pay the landlord you could you could
have a lot of sleepless nights so you've
done it really well you know you've done
your market research you're operating in
an area that you know because you know
if there you've been trained you've got
the correct contracts and then it's a
case of just ready to smash it out fast
just learn with everyone as well we've
got so much from doing the first deal of
course well the thing is if your thing
is I always feel like and I'm sure you
guys would agree there's over here this
extreme this is people that go on
courses and don't take any action yeah
and knowledge without implementation
will lead to no results searchers
but then over here you have people who
take massive action
they don't take the proper training and
they don't know what they're doing and
these people would call motivated idiots
that can get really burnt and it's very
dangerous and then in the middle you've
got Duda trained in you know read the
right books talk to the right people get
the knowledge but then take action and
there's a nice sweet spot I think you
guys have got that just right and that's
why you know you're going just right you
know you've not bought on loads and
loads of courses and spent you know but
you've gone on you've taken the right
steps you've got on the right train and
you've got the right mentor and like you
guys aren't even on the academy I know
you did some you know a day which is
great but you still smashing out the
park which is absolutely fantastic so
talk to me as well I agree
the best way to learn is to do yeah so
talk to me about some of the lessons
that you've learned in doing these deals
what would you say lesson number one
would be definitely do all the
electricity and gas first because we
treat work on properties and basically
about the property mmm and we found out
the gas electricity hasn't actually been
changed over because because they never
answer the phone yeah they make sure all
of that is to say take this all about
yourself rather than the landlord doing
in those cases you have to make sure
gets done changed over properly what are
the lessons we had along that's a really
good lesson it's one of those things you
know you probably wouldn't read that in
a book yeah yeah it's just one of those
things you've just got a doing that's
one of the things you learn by actually
actually getting the first day when I
was at off what do i do you know yeah
always confirmed with people who want to
view a couple of hours before you in the
morning or the evening before we've got
two viewings and people have said yeah
mom away 20 minutes and then they've
never turned up
Wow which is yeah annoyingly in 2019
people's word is not their bond yeah
yeah yeah you know when I started out in
property like 10 12 years ago if someone
said they were gonna be there there were
going to be there yes but now it's like
you've got a text and confirm and now
they're for 15 minutes before because
you guys are talking about tenants or
yeah even agents even agents about yeah
oh yeah you know you just have to just
have to check out what people make sure
this
No yeah all right and what's the biggest
like these are obviously some of the
challenges yeah yeah but in regards to
some of the successes maybe winning the
deal or or getting a maximum rent what
are some of the biggest lessons that
you've learned through the successes of
what you've done I think when we took on
our first one we were going to kind of
let it out how it was considering we
didn't have much money at all and we got
it we pretty much got the property for
free and then we decided to use credit
cards and one and actually do the
property up get it painted and whatnot
and we found that but definitely
spending some money on the property was
was it was a good point for us cuz now
now we now we do the most of them what
will paint most of them because you just
get a rented out so much quicker people
come around they appreciate the fact
that little touches that you put in the
room suppose they really like it so I
think that stuff is really important to
getting a let out it really helps so
that helps to our success in regards to
renting the rooms out quicker in regards
to finding more deals I would probably
say what's the big lesson probably just
when you go when you when you going into
viewings and going into meetings with
agents and stuff just you know act we've
always been sort of acted confident and
actually what we've done this a million
times before and that served us really
well because you know they then get the
feeling that you're serious about what
you're doing and yeah take on loads and
then won't give you too many at once and
you have to figure out what you're gonna
do yeah I think be confident have good
posture because yeah you might think I'm
saying the wrong things I'm saying the
wrong things but they don't know what
you're planning on saying in this place
yeah I love that so be confident get the
right skills gasp confirm appointment
how do you spot a good like what is it
what are you looking for an XO what is a
good deal with rent to rent I would say
so with the minimum we so we will work
out when with a minimum amount of profit
we want to take as five hundred pounds
so none of them cash flow that little
for us yet but that's like as low as
we're willing to go yeah so if there's a
deal that comes along it's going to cash
flow 500 pounds and it doesn't really
need a much spending on it we would
happily take that deal yeah what we do
is we work out sort of you know so the
ones we've got at the moment the cash
flow seven eight hundred power
that's great how much do we need to
spend on them so we work out basically
we kind of want to break even within six
months I mean even if you've got the
deal for three or five years you know
you can go longer than I know some
people go to that ten months and stuff
like that but we normally hope to break
even most of time within six months yes
that's that's okay so what you mean is
if you're going to put down five
thousand yeah then you want to be able
to make that back within the first six
months which is going to give you a 200%
return on investment exactly yeah so I
mean and I teach a variation you'll know
a very conservative you want to make at
least a hundred percent ROI in the first
year so two hundred percent is fantastic
so what whereabouts as well I mean are
you looking and you've got a particular
Street or particular or you just
generally looking around
obviously we're from commentary so know
the area quite well and we know we
generally in Coventry we generally
invest sort of around the city centre
and a couple of a hotspots just because
we're from there we know where the
demand is sort of thing so yeah and then
as we pick as we pick somewhat if we do
demand if we do research on one and the
demand is good and we actually get the
deal and test it out then we know that
that Street and that area is good and
will happily rinse and repeat in that
area do you have any break cause if it
doesn't work we have on some of them if
we do put a lot of money into the
property with one landlord and we have a
first anniversary break close to 12
months yeah initially so in the contract
that we use if we're going to over to
landlord there is no there's a break
clause first after the first anniversary
so after the first year but not for them
yeah and then when we go through agents
they usually look to put a break cause
in for six months in case of landlord I
appeal we're not happy but because we're
prepared to spend when you add value to
the property we explain that and then we
try and get we'll get at least a 12
month break laws so that we don't lose
out on any money we've invested yeah
sure so basically the ideal setup is if
you have a break clause so you're gonna
say to the landlord look I'm spending
two three grands yeah doing this place
up it's a bit it's a bit dirty I'm gonna
paint it and that's my commitment to you
to show that I'm serious
however if after a year or I want to
pull out because it's not written out as
well as I thought I want to have a break
clause it's a five-year contract but a
break clause to pull out however I will
leave you a property in better condition
then I took it on so that kind is that
the kind of thing that you
that's exactly what it is and they're
happy with that because it essentially
we are literally adding value to their
property yes we're so going today they
own and on most cases you know we were
putting furniture and uh stuff like that
and the reality is when it comes to the
end of the deal I can't see us bring the
round of man and taking all that
furniture back out and moving it to
another house so they're most likely
gonna get yeah I know it's a really good
point because if you say looking I'll
furnish it and I'll leave you with the
furniture oh wow that sounds great but
come on let's face it in five years time
yeah you're not gonna want anyone no
that's fantastic so what what kind of
contracts do you use them for in too
much because I know that's a really
important sure yes so we've got from
basically yeah well it's I think it's
called a lease agreement contract isn't
it it's a special rental rent contract
we've got from one of our courses so and
that's the contract so it was already
luckily for us it was already made for
us
yeah and had all the clauses in there
yeah aw do I see my solicitor or not so
and it's really important that you use a
management contract rather than if you
just have a normal AST yeah and then you
then rent it out on another st and
that's called subletting yeah yeah I get
it - really it's a really that one's a
problem yeah we first went through the
contract as well
there was clauses in there that we never
thought you'd even need yeah so you
definitely need to get the right
contractor ninja persona because if
anything go wrong literally one thing
that and we didn't even know that it was
in the contract
yeah I put it in that yes I think you
know you can use management agreements
corporately yeah but just make sure that
I would definitely advise and I'm sure
you would as well getting advice on that
and it also depends on what you're doing
and of course every deal is different as
well I mean with lease option agreements
you need a solicitor yeah we've rent to
rents you can use it again and again but
it's got to be right yeah so what's your
more be your biggest advice for someone
who was in your shoes six months ago
that was thinking I really want to get
my first rent to rent deal what would
you advise him to do just need to keep
motivated do your research go to as many
courses and meet as many people as you
can
yeah and for us it was really getting
around the right people and basically
connecting and meeting up with people
who were in our industry of what we
wanted to do so we've allowed of people
who were doing not read to rent and
that's how we basically sort of got our
answers to our questions
kind of just the last little questions
that we needed to get that speak to
somebody who's already doing it you know
so I would say that work is why we
literally just made a YouTube just
recorded a YouTube video on this the
other day and this is we were saying how
vital it is to just stay motivated keep
on going for it and and and find people
that are in your field doing what you
want to do have the conversations with
them because when it comes to getting a
deal you're gonna be like oh my god what
do I do now and if you've got people
there will be people at your local
events and stuff that I do in restaurant
or even hate tumors in general and
they'll be able to advise your the next
steps and how to go about this and that
so I definitely say you know build some
good contacts now that's great
so your business plan six months ago we
we ripped it up yeah and we started
getting which we're going to focus on
went to rents yeah we actually I think I
think we said from from memory when you
when you'll make it about four or five
grand a month yeah perhaps we can then
move on to other strategy so what's next
for you guys so we've got a pretty big
vision for this year actually we
actually want to get to 48 rentals by
the end of 2009 we want a lot so we
really have focused on rental and now we
want to go for it so this year by the
end of this year we want 48
that'll be turning over a million plus
and that's one of our goals as well and
then also at some point in the year we
want to be able to step back a little
bit and hire somebody to sort of take
care of the management decisions and
stuff like that system oiler so we can
step back and then take on another
strata we're not sure what yet but we
definitely want to start what sounds
like you're super laser focus yeah yeah
which is and you can now getting results
yes definitely yeah talk to me a little
bit about mindset because I think that
I'm one of the reasons I think most
people fail is because they taught
themselves out of it they have a bad
mindset that I can't do attitude instead
of can-do attitude how important is that
been to you what advice would you give
around that fundamental absolutely
fundamental I mean both Jessica and
myself we both write down our goals
every single morning and everything we
even it's the first time I wake up
lasting for go to bed I personally have
19 goals and I know more of a heart
write them down and that helps me stay
focused because you know I've got a very
positive attitude and just listening to
audiobooks reading books about business
in the industry also about mindset and
how to stay positive from the influence
and influential people out there and
yeah it's just so important just to stay
just to stay motivated
just have the can-do attitude just know
just a vision sort of where you go and
know you can do and as possible and then
map out a plan of what you've gotta do
to get there learn I think it's I think
it's I don't think you can really do it
without being positive or no and you can
do it and believing in yourself yes it's
also good that we have each other as
well because if I have a fill down or
not doing something you know he gives me
a kick back up and likewise so it is
good that we do have each other on the
same mission love that you guys are an
awesome couple
what advice would you give to someone
that we've weighing up whether to book
on to the free property investors crash
course like I said we've spent thousands
upon forces before and we store name
crash course number one just because I'm
not just saying that I'm saying that
because of the amount of value that I
just said previously that you get in the
crash course so you have to you have to
do it yeah if anybody ever comes to me
on Facebook from our YouTube comes to me
from Facebook and Instagram how do I get
into property and I'll say the first
thing I'd recommend to you before I give
you any of my time is to go on the
stream and you'll learn everything you
need to know I've said that to numbers
and numbers of people you guys are
awesome well listen man thank you so
much for coming on the show reach out to
me anytime hundreds I'm super proud of
you guys and yeah you're amazing thank
you for bringing Josh you're welcome
painting so much my name is Samuel Leeds
thank you for watching winners on a
Wednesday every single week we interview
a success students for your inspiration
you can watch more right here on the
playlist as a whole playlist of them to
what you'll notice is every single
winner on a Wednesday always starts with
them coming to my two day crash course
so if you would like to be a winner on a
Wednesday
literally come on my crash course and
who knows in three months time you could
be here in my offices on this show as a
winner on a Wednesday so get yourself
booked on the crash course watch more
have fun I'll see you next week